like is this gonna be the end of San
Francisco being like the place and
what's what's what's a with the world
like in Austin right now the crazy
everything's crazy I don't think it's as
bad as San Francisco but the world is
crazy I I decided to we got a new office
down here and so I've rented a house to
see everyone and it's cool Austin's a
great city what do you think is gonna
happen to San Francisco do you think
it's gonna like is this gonna be the end
of San Francisco being like the place I
think so yeah I think so for a couple
reasons we you know right now I'm
selling my house yeah so say your your
house looks different you're decorating
it to sell aren't you yeah I'm trying to
sell my house right now so it's about to
go up for sale and I'm trying to move to
the suburbs of the Bay Area but and so
right now because I'm doing that I'm in
the middle of the market and listening
to people and scurrying you know what
are they what's it like I'm Mike is the
market hot to sell am I gonna get a good
price when I try to go look for
something else is there a lot of stuff
available or is it a bidding war and you
know just like you would expect there's
sort of a you know a flight to the
flight to space right now and not like
the SpaceX kind I'm talking about like
physical house space
people need urbanization yeah do
religions people are leaving cities
they're leaving San Francisco for sure
so a lot of people were in San Francisco
or here because of the career
opportunities and now that the tech
companies are saying you know either we
are already remote or we're going remote
or way more remote friendly and your
work from home for the summer
foreseeable future here there's
basically no the premium the extreme
premium I mean like one bedroom for four
grand a month
two bedrooms six grand a month you know
type of rents to be in the city and so
like you know when a when a studio condo
is a million dollars in the city you
know if you don't have to pay that
you're not going to and so people want
space people want more affordability and
people want to be away from like a whole
bunch of other people from this virus
and so that is driving a lot of people
out of the cities now some people say oh
that's just temporary personally I don't
think so I
think you can put the genie back in the
bottle once the companies start letting
you be removed and it doesn't matter
where you're physically located why
would you live in a more expensive area
only if that lifestyle really appeals to
you which it will for like twenty
something year olds right to be in
cities but right now you get the twenty
something year olds and the 30 something
year olds because the 30 something year
olds are there for their career and
that's gonna go away I feel like I've
been in Austin for a week now I'm I'm
gonna stay for another week maybe I'll
stay one more week down here it is
definitely happier like the way of life
like it for me and for many others I
understand why you'd happier here
like dude money a house I got I got a
pool I'm like a swimming pool like what
is this this is amazing that makes me
happy just looking at the swimming pool
I like it too my thing though is I miss
San Francisco I want to come back I do
miss a little bit of a struggle I also
miss the people I hate the people and a
dangerous San Francisco has like actual
you know real problems with crime and
homelessness and stuff like that I don't
think anybody wants that and where
they're living it I think you know
there's part of it that's the energy of
the city I love being in New York I love
being at fdisk I'm around all these
energizing interesting ambitious people
a bunch of single people but then
there's just like crime and homelessness
and like extreme expenses that put a
burden on you and I think that's nobody
likes that I almost feel like not a real
way but just because I can't think of a
better word a little homeless where I'm
like well where the is my place now
like where's my like you know yeah you
and I we're not quite similar you've
done it more than I have but me too and
a lesser extent I've lived in many
different cities and I finally felt like
I had a home in San Francisco and now
I'm like like it's wait like damn
it's way different and so I'm I'm pretty
sad about it to be honest like I've been
like depressed over it I'm also sad
obviously about all the other shit's
going on
you
[Music]
[Applause]